pour les parents d'enfants à besoins
particuliers faire une sortie culturelle
n'est pas toujours synonyme de plaisir
cybèle robichaud mère de frédéric et
directrice de la programmation du centre
des sciences de montréal on sait quelque
chose des filles de
déplacement il ya un défi
d'accessibilité il ya un défi parfois
aussi au niveau comportemental
on sait la lumière une sur stimulation
par le bruit par la présence de
plusieurs autres visiteurs ça peut créer
un obstacle à la visite c'est dans ce
contexte que le centre des sciences de
montréal lancent les 14 novembre 12
décembre et 16 janvier les matinées
apaisé destiné aux enfants qui par
exemple ont un handicap physique ou
intellectuel un trouble du spectre de
l'autisme ou un trouble du développement
qu'on veut faire c'est vraiment offrir
un milieu sécuritaire
avec en fait du plaisir sans compromis
au cours du projet pilote seuls les
enfants à besoins particuliers et leurs
accompagnateurs pourront accéder au
musée entre 9h et 11h on accueillera
aussi moins de visiteurs
grâce aux conseils de professionnels
tout a été réfléchi de l'aménagement du
mobilier à la hauteur des fiches
signalétiques en passant par la
formation des employés et la création
d'un guide pour les parents
l'apesi d'apaiser les parents qui vont
être moins inquiet et qui vont avoir
laissé ce que leurs enfants vont pouvoir
vivre la même expérience que n'importe
quel autre enfant
iris gagnon n'a pas à craindre la
présence de lumière stroboscopique qui
pourrait déclencher chez elle une crise
d'épilepsie mais je trouve ça très
gentil et que c'est une bonne idée que
tous les musées devraient faire ça ça
enlève du stress et ça fait que je
n'ai plus envie de venir le centre
adaptera aussi le niveau de bruit et la
durée de ses représentations dans sa
salle imax l'une des grandes fiertés de
cybèle robichaud la salle de bains muni
d'une table à langer pour les plus
grands enfants pour éviter d'avoir à les
changer par terre ça change tout en
thermique dame enceinte talent mais
également en termes je pense humain
si le projet est concluant les matinées
apesi pourraient être intégrées à
l'horaire du musée sur une base
régulière ici valérie michaela bayne
radio canada montréal